[Music]
today marks a special day for PC Gamers
the return of the $250 us graphics card
and what we're getting here from Intel
looks pretty good that's right it's
Intel who is apparently saving PC gaming
by delivering a GPU that's faster than
both the GeForce RTX 460 and radon RX
7600 while costing less and crucially
packing more vram 12 GB instead of just
eight this new new graphics card is
called The Arc b580 it's based on the
new xe2 architecture and it's designed
for 1440p gaming the highlights of the
xe2 architecture include the second
generation XE core with sd16 execution
offering major efficiency improvements a
new and improved rate racing unit
offering two times the throughput and
second generation xmx engines in terms
of specifications the b580 has been
manufactured using tsmc's 5 n process
packing 19.6 billion transistors into a
272 s mm die in total there are 20 XE
cores 160 XE Vector engines 160 xmx
Matrix engines 20 RT units 160 tmus and
80 RS the cores come clocked at
2670 MHz but can boost as high as 2,850
MHz the memory subsystem includes 12 GB
of gddr6 memory running at 19 GB per
second on a 192bit wide memory bus
resulting in a memory bandwidth of 456
GB per second the board power rating has
been set at 190 wat and it uses a PCI
4.0 * 8 interface on hand for testing we
have the Intel Arc b580 limited edition
graphics card though we do have a few
aib models on hand though we can't test
those for another 24 hours
the limited edition model us its Intel
signature stealth black design and this
is a dual fan model the PCB is very
compact so the second fan blows through
the card as for testing we're using our
updated GPU test system featuring The
ryzen 7 9800x 3D so all of the data
featured in this video is new it's all
up to date and has been collected over
the past week there's loads of data to
go over so let's get into
it we'll start with Star Wars J Survivor
and at 1080p the b580 looks quite good
beating the RTX 460 by a 7% margin and
the RX 7600 by a 10% margin it was 5%
slower than the 6700 XT and 7% slower
than the RTX 36 TI though still if we
increase the resolution to 1440p we're
looking at 51 FPS using the maximum
in-game quality settings so that's
without upscaling enabled and this was
enough to match the 6700 X T and that
meant it was now 16% faster than the
4060 and 19% faster than the 7600 so
very impressive margins there next up we
have a plague toil requium and here the
b580 looks great rendering 77 FPS at
1080p this meant it was 18% faster than
the 7600 and 20% faster than the 4060
and really it wasn't that much slower
than the 4060 TI the 1440p results are
much the same the b580 was 21% faster
than the 7600 and 24% faster than the
4060 performance overall wasn't amazing
with just 56 FPS on average but again we
are using the highest quality preset and
it is possible to enable upscaling to
boost the frame rates above 60
FPS now cyberpunk 2077 Phantom Liberty
hasn't been tested using the highest
possible quality preset instead we've
gone with the high preset and then
disabled upscaling so we're testing at
the native 1080p resolution
under these conditions the b580 was able
to render 90 FPS which is an 11%
improvement over the 7600 and 15% over
the 4060 that also placed it on power
the 6700 XT and 360
TI now at 1440p it does even better
relative to competing parts and is very
close to the 4060 TI rendering 63 FPS
that made it 19% faster than the 7600
and a massive 29% faster than the 4060
so incredibly impressive results here
and a quick side note we're not using
the built-in Benchmark for measuring
performance in cyberpunk 2077 rather we
are testing in
game another game where Intel's new b580
looks impressive is Dying Light to here
we're again looking at 4060 TI like
performance delivering 74 FPS at 1080p
this made it 177% faster than the 460
and 21% faster than the 7600
then quite remarkably at 1440p the b580
managed to nudge ahead of the 4060 TI
allbe It by a single frame so the same
performance overall but for a $250 us
graphics card this is very impressive
and as a result it was 25% faster than
the 4060 and 34% faster than the 7600 so
yeah a super result
here the b580 did stumble a little in
Dragon Age the vard and while it did
match the 6700 XT which would normally
be really impressive it was 15% slower
than the 4060 and we're looking at just
52 FPS on average at 1080p so not great
performance overall but similar to what
we're seeing from comparable radio on
gpus in this
title however something a little odd
about the b580 is that it often scales
very differently across resolutions when
compared to the radon and GeForce gpus
and we're getting a look of that here
increas in the resolution to 1440p only
reduced the b580 performance by 177%
whereas the RTX 460 saw a 37%
performance hit and as a result is now
slightly slower than the
b580 now a big reason for this is down
to vram though that doesn't explain
everything as the b580 should scale
better at 1080p but at 1440p the RX 7600
does run out of vram resulting in very
poor performance the 8 GB GeForce gpus
they don't suffer as much but the 8 GB
40 62i was still up to 11% slower than
the 16 GB model chances are if we played
the game beyond the period of time that
it takes to run our benchmarks the 8 GB
GeForce gpus would suffer more anyway
the fact that the b580 has 12 GB of vram
it does help it here not only to deliver
better average frame rate performance
but also more consistent frame times
next up we have War Thunder and here the
b580 works well though it is only 5%
faster than the 7600 and 7% faster than
the 4060 on the other hand though it was
able to match the 7700 XT and 360 TI and
we see a bit more separation at 1440p as
here the b580 is 11% faster than the
7600 and 16% faster than the 4060 so
overall great performance from Intel's
latest Arc
GPU next up we have Spider-Man
remastered and I had to triple check
this data because the b580 just looked
far too good rendering 152 FPS on
average at 1080P and our test which is
comparable performance to the 4060 TI
and we have seen this already but in
this example that made it almost 70%
faster than the 460 and almost 50%
faster than the
7600 and what's interesting about this
is that the margins were actually
reduced at
1440p and this is the first time we're
actually seeing this still even here the
B5
was 43% faster than the 4060 and 47%
faster than the 7600 so amazing results
overall the b580 wasn't nearly as
impressive in Hogwarts Legacy matching
the performance of the 4060 at 1080p
with 71 FPS and this meant it was 7%
slower than the RX 7600 still
performance overall is decent using the
high quality preset and the b580 does
scale a little bit better at 1440p as
it's now able to match the 7600 making
it 11% faster than the
4060 sadly the Space Marine 2
performance at 1080p isn't great and
although 62 FPS on average is very
playable it does mean that the b580 is
16% slower than the 4060 and 18% slower
than the 7600 so very disappointing data
in that respect and here we have another
example where the b580 drops only a
small amount of performance when
increasing the resolution to 1440p and
as a result in this example it is able
to nudge ahead of the RTX 4060 still not
amazing performance but given the price
it is
passable moving on to the Last of Us
Part One at 1080p we find pretty strong
performance from the b580 with 75 FPS on
average and that meant it was 10% faster
than the 4060 and 14% faster than the
7600 then at 1440p using the ultra
quality preset in the section of the
game that we use for testing you will
run into performance issues with 8 GB of
vram
although the average frame rate looks
fine you will often see horrible frame
stuttering which smashes the 1% lows
down like what you're seeing here so
while the b580 isn't impressive 29%
faster than the 4060 When comparing the
average frame rate it's
110% faster when comparing 1% lows it's
also worth noting that with 54 FPS on
average the b580 is able to deliver
playable
performance next up we have Star Wars
Outlaws and with the initial review
driver we had a lot of stability issues
in this title but thankfully before the
release intel was able to roll out a new
driver which solved these issues and
that allowed me to test Outlaws without
any problems so with that solved the
b580 was 18% faster than both the 4060
and 7600 so a great result here though
we are only looking at 40 FPS at 1080p
so you'd have to lower the quality
preset Andor enable upscaling
and that being the case 1440p is really
out of the question so you will need to
lower the quality settings in this title
but that was obviously also the case for
most of the graphics cards tested here
last up we have Starfield and the b580
didn't perform that well here at least
in the section of the game that we use
for testing Not only was the average
frame rate quite low coming in 20% lower
than that of the RTX 460 for example but
the frame Time Performance was also
quite poor and this is the same issue
we've seen in the past f with the
a770 given what we saw at 1080p 1440p is
obviously out of the question not just
because of the weak frame Time
Performance but also because we're
looking at just 30 FPS on average not
exactly a great gaming
experience okay so here's a look at the
12 game average performance at 1080P and
as you can see the b580 stacks up quite
well delivering on average 7% greater
performance than the RTX 4060 and 8%
greater performance than the RX7
7600 certainly not mindblowing margins
by any stretch of the imagination and it
is worth noting that the 7600 and 4060
have been out in the wild for a year and
a half now and are expected to be
replaced sometime within the next 6
months so while the b580 looks good for
$250 us it is competing with much older
products all of that said it does
perform much better relative to the 7600
and 4060 at 1440p delivering 14% GR
performance than the 460 and 21% greater
performance than the
7600 that placed it alongside the RTX 36
tii and just ahead of the 6700 XT which
I'd say is pretty great performance for
the asking price now in terms of power
consumption the b580 isn't amazing but
it's also not bad in Star Wars Outlaws
for example it consumed 22% more power
than the
4060 which worked out to be a 49 watt
increase it was 8% faster in this
example which helps but of course the
GeForce GPU is still more power
efficient in Starfield we're looking at
just a 16% power increase over the 4060
as here the b580 consumed roughly the
same amount of power as the RX 7600
though the 4060 was also 23% faster in
this example so not a good title for the
b580 in terms of
efficiency then finally we have some
power usage numbers in Space Marine 2
and here the b580 consumed 27% more
power than the 4060 which equates to a
56 wat increase the b580 was 6% faster
though now just quickly before we move
on here's a look at how the Intel Arc
b580 limited edition graphics card runs
under load testing takes place inside an
enclosed ATX case with a room
temperature of 21° and here the b580 GPU
peaked at just
62° with a peak memory temperature of
70° the cor is ran at 2,850 MHz and we
typically saw a fan speed of between
1250 and 1350 RPM so underload the card
ran very cool and quiet okay so it's
time to take a look at some R tracing
performance and for this we have six
games all of which have been carefully
selected Tim spent a few months testing
the effectiveness of rtfx in a broad
range of titles and found games such as
Metro Exodus enhanced Allen wake 2
cyberp Punk 2077 Phantom Liberty
Marvel's Spider-Man remastered black
myth Wukong and Dying Light to stay
human were amongst the best to showcase
the technology offering what Tim called
better overall to transformative visuals
now for all of this testing I will be
using quality upscaling at 1080P and
1440p so that means dlss for the Nvidia
graphics cards that support it and then
FSR for the radon gpus and then any
GeForce gpus that don't support dlss and
then finally we have XS for the arc gpus
so let's see how the b580 handles rro in
but 53% faster than the
7600 I really expected the b580 to be
very crippled in alen Wake 2 to the same
degree as the 7600 for example but it
managed respectable performance relative
to the RTX 4060 of course these settings
which we deem transformative can't
really be run on these graphics cards
even the 4060 was only able to average
30 FPS and that's with quality dlss
enabled so while Allen wake 2 is a good
example of a game with excellent rate
racing it sadly cannot be enjoyed on a
current generation Nvidia GPU that costs
less than $600 us and that being the
case 1440p is obviously completely out
of the question but since we have the
data here it is even the RTX 470 is
Highly Questionable here now for
cyberpunk 2077 the minimum acceptable
rage racing quality setting is ultra
which Tim claimed generally offers
better overall image quality while the
over overdrive mode is transformative
but there's simply no chance you can run
the overdrive mode on an RTX 4060 tier
product so I've had to settle with the
generally better visual option in Ultra
rate tracing at 1080p the b580 was
actually faster than the RTX 4060
rendering 58 FPS on average and that's a
14% performance boost it's near enough
to 60 FPS which some people will be
happy with though having to use
upscaling at a low resolution such as
1080p is is suboptimal I'd say then at
1440p it's a real struggle but relative
to the 4060 the b580 is impressive
rendering 41 FPS which made it nearly
60%
faster now for testing Marvel's
Spider-Man remastered we have maxed out
the visuals including the rate tracing
options as Tim says this leads to a
generally better overall presentation
when compared to no rate racing at all
oddly however the b580 was the slowest
GPU tested here rendering just 67 FPS
making it 20% slower than the RTX 460 so
a very disappointing result there but if
we increase the resolution the b580 sees
almost no change in performance as a
result is now just 12% slower than the
4060 as unusual as these results are
they have been confirmed by Intel and at
the point of putting this review
together they didn't have an answer for
me as to why we're seeing this odds
scaling Behavior with the
b580 black myth Wukong was unstable on
the b580 with the initial review driver
but intel was again able to solve this
before reviews went live with a new
driver update so we were able to
complete our testing without any crashes
but unfortunately with very high quality
raate tracing enabled which Tim claims
generally looks better overall none of
the sub $400 US gpus were able to
deliver acceptable performance so the
fact that the 4060 was 84% faster than
the b580 is largely irrelevant here and
that being the case there's really no
need to go over the 1440p results but
since I have the data here it is you can
have a quick
look next we have Dying Light 2 using
the high rate tracing preset which we
believe generally looks better overall
and here the b580 was able to average 62
FPS making it 11% faster than the 4060
and 41% faster than the 7600 so a great
result here for Intel then at 1440p
we're looking at 45 FPS which isn't a
great experience in my opinion
especially given we're already using
upscaling still the b580 was 18% faster
than the 4060 and 67% faster than the RX
7600 now here's the six game average for
the rate tracing results at 1080P and on
average the b580 was 20% slower than the
4060 but 55% faster than the RX
7600 But a lot of this data has to be
taken with a grain of salt because the
RTX 460 was unusable in my opinion in
some of the games tested even at 1080p
games such as Allen wake 2 and black
myth Wukong for example then at 144p the
b580 was 18% slower than the RTX 460 but
in games such as Allen wake 2 cyberpunk
2077 Dying Light 2 and black myth Wukong
the GeForce GPU was rendering well below
60 FPS on average and that's with
quality dlss enabled so not a great
experience
there okay so now it's time for the all
important cost per Frame data and this
is where the ark b580 really shines
thanks to its $250 us MSRP based on the
1440p data the b580 is coming in at a
24% discount per frame when compared to
the RX 7600 and 27% when compared to the
RTX
460 now prior to the release of the b580
Tim and myself agreed that if intel
could achieve a 20% discount relative to
the the RTX 4060 it would be a success
so given we're seeing over a 20%
discount here it's looking like the b580
will be a success but first let's take a
look at real world retail pricing even
at current retail pricing the b580 is
still 21% cheaper than the 7600 per
frame and the same 27% discount relative
to the RTX 460 applies so if you were to
go out and buy an arc b580 graphics card
at launch you'd be getting yourself a
great deal in my opinion I think it's
fair to say the b580 is a great value
graphics card certainly in the current
market and the cost per Frame data
clearly shows that it's at least 20%
better value than competing parts and
only some of that data takes into
account the fact that you're getting 50%
more vram measuring the value of
additional vram can be difficult as
short Benchmark passes often don't
expose VM capacities that are right on
or just over the limmit they also don't
out for games that reduce texture
quality and in fact in some of those
examples the performance can actually
increase on models with insufficient
vram but what I can tell you is this
going from 8 GB to 12 GB of vram is
invaluable and it will make the b580
significantly more capable than either
the RX 7600 or RTX 460 moving forward so
if you factored that into the equation
the b580 really is significantly better
value than anything AMD or Nvidia have
to offer right now in in terms of
stability the b580 was good not Flawless
in our testing but certainly good enough
given the price I'm also a lot less
concerned with stability and
compatibility given the improvements
Intel's made over the years and even
during the review process most of the
issues that we ran into were solved
before the reviews were set to go live
all of that said you're more likely to
run into issues with the b580 than you
are with an RX 7600 or RTX 460 which is
why we believe a 20% discount is
warranted and Intel has certainly
delivered that I also don't think power
consumption is an issue here using
around 50 Watts more than the RTX 4060
is an ideal but it's far from a deal
breaker again given the large discount
on offer here likewise I'm not too
fussed with the rate tracing performance
of the
b580 Intel have claimed that it is meant
to be better than the RTX 4060 and look
that could well be the case in titles
that don't have use RT effects and there
are plenty of those in fact it is really
the vast majority but for games that do
generally look better with rt and abled
or better yet can be considered
transformative the RTX 4060 is generally
the faster option but it also generally
sucks in terms of performance so raid
tracing really shouldn't be a priority
for really any graphics cards that cost
less than $600 us as it stands if you're
in the market for a graphics card and
want to spend less than $300 us your
options are extremely limited and they
have been for quite some time for the
longest time the RX 6600 has been the
go-to option but with just 34 FPS on
average at 1440p in our 12 game sample
the b580 was almost 70% faster so paying
around 30% more while getting 50% more
vram is well worth it and really you
wouldn't entertain the RX 6600 anymore
for those of you who want a game at 4
40p the RX 6600 will have to use medium
to low quality settings so I feel with
the arrival of the b580 AMD really can't
charge more than about $130 us for the
6600 likewise to compete with the b580
the RX 7600 needs to drop down to
$200 and even then it wouldn't be all
that compelling given that it only has 8
GB of vram I think $180 would be a more
attractive price point so that's pretty
bad news for AMD they need to prices by
at least
30% likewise the RTX 4060 needs to drop
from the current $300 us asking price
down to $200 us at most and I really
can't see that happening therefore for
entry level gaming the b580 is now the
new go-to Option it's really impossible
to recommend anything else so great job
there Intel they've achieved with their
second generation what they failed to do
with their first and on that note in my
opinion Intel has to fully commit to Arc
at this point as in the discreet desktop
gpus over the years there's been a lot
of talk suggesting Intel will ax
discrete desktop gpus after the initial
battle mage release so Parts like the
b580 and I'm not saying this won't
happen but what I am saying is this
would be an epic fail on Intel's behalf
if they choose to do so in my opinion
things with Arc have been heading in the
right direction and while they have a
long way to go giving up now would be a
disaster
and on a final note Intel does have the
b570 coming in the next month for $220
us and that model packs a 10 GB vram
buffer and that being the case I expect
that the b580 will be worth the small
$30 us premium so if you like what
you've seen here it's probably not worth
waiting on that note the only concern I
have right now is availability I've
talked with a few retailers and they've
all told me that pre-sales for the b580
have been unexpectedly High High selling
all of the stock they were able to get
their hands on so it seems even prior to
the reviews people were excited to get a
graphics card that Intel claims is
faster than RTX 460 for $250 us with 12
GB of vram so given how good Intel's
b580 is availability for at least a few
months is probably going to be very
limited uh it's what you might call a
high class problem though for Intel but
for buyers it's going to be quite
annoying anyway it's great to finally
have a sub $300 us graphics card worth
recommending and I'm Keen to see how
Intel develops the ark B series also let
me know what you think about the b580 in
the comment section below I'll be sure
to read all of your feedback and if you
enjoyed the video don't forget to like
also subscribe because we will be doing
some big Benchmark comparisons with this
GPU probably against the RTX 4060 to
start off something like that cuz that's
probably one of the more popular
entrylevel gpus let's say any anyway
more content coming up so make sure you
subscribe also you can hit the join
button if you want to become a harbor
unbox member we also have patreon you'll
get access to our exclusive Discord
server behind the scenes content monthly
live streams and Q&A stuff but anyway
that is going to do it for this one I'm
your host Steve see you again next time
[Music]